yeah thanks for the warm welcome
as he said i'm jan and i'm going to talk
about making music with javascript and
gamepads and
last year i had the chance to
attend js conf
eu i didn't have the money but there was
a company that made a raffle and
the name is dot cloud
and
well thank you dark cloud um
when i was there there was
this one talk that really blew my mind
and it was this talk here
uh it was stuart memo's talk javascript
is the new punk rock and it highly hey
jan uh inspired me to uh
hold a talk here now
so what what are you going what can you
expect from this talk so so first i'm
i'm going to give a quick introduction
to the web audio api like really quick
and just some demos
then i will talk about the gamepad api
that makes this possible here
and then in the end i will
combine these two apis to create music
uh
let's see how that goes um i have to say
both of these apis are still draft apis
so they're kind of unstable so please
bear with me if something breaks
and
it's only working in chrome for now i
know web audio is also supported in
firefox but
i would have to use two polyfills in my
demos and they are unstable without
their polyfills i don't know if it's
better if i want to have two polyfolds
so yeah
the web audio api what is it i think
many of you heard of it
it's a low level access in javascript to
all things audio which means
we can create sounds we can
manipulate sounds with filters
uh we can time sounds very precisely
which is new and which is for me one of
the biggest features and
there's tons of other cool stuff i will
not mention for example spatial audio
and audio analysis for example spatial
audio is you can say that the sound
source comes from
there and it's pointing to that
direction and
the audio api is capable of
emulating um
the the sound of the room so it actually
sounds evidence as it is as if the sound
comes from there
but before um
what is sound like do you feel
comfortable with your physics knowledge
about sounds and waves like i don't who
doesn't
all right
okay half of your physicists right
so uh sound is a mechanical wave that's
an oscillation of pressure
it's transmitted through some medium in
our case air are composed of frequencies
within the range of hearing
so what it means like i stopped my feet
did you hear it okay um
this created a wave it went through the
air into your ear and it had a frequency
you could hear
and
what the sound looked like because um
when we're talking about frequencies and
uh waves
like that's very abstract to me but this
is a very nice image that shows uh a
speaker just like the speakers here
everywhere
at the slow motion it's playing a 61
hertz
sound and you can really see the the the
sine wave it's doing so it really
creates sine waves in the end
yeah but let's get
like into the web audio api let's let's
oscillate ourselves like
uh
if we're doing something with the web
audio api we first have to create a
context that's very similar to
the canvas api because context is where
we have all our methods
and then we can create an oscillator
which creates waves
we create it simply from the context
then we can say okay this oscillator
should be of type 0 which means it
creates sine waves
and we we set the frequency value to 22k
so it will create a wave of 22k
and then what we do we have the
oscillator and we have the context and
the context knows about the speakers so
we need to connect the oscillator to the
speakers it's done by
oscillator.connect con context
destination so
if we didn't do that we wouldn't hear it
because
no output and then what we have to do is
say note on like play it right now
and
did anyone spot the
biological mistake in that one
yes he's right we can't hear 22k um i
would i will show you um
i i forgot to plug in
guard
you wouldn't hear it because it's not
plugged in
oh thanks
sorry
oh it's very loud
so are there any cats
inside this room because
oh god okay this might be this this
might hurt so i play the 22 kilohertz
you're not hearing anything because
you're humans no cats okay
uh so now let's
this might not sound like real music to
you maybe it might sound like music to
aliens but not for us
so
this is now playing a
sign with with a very low frequency we
can do
and if we have like a different um
type of wave they sound even worse like
you want uh it's a square
i got
uh well you can do the same
and
base
and you have the triangle which is way
more condensed
very stable okay
so this is like the the most basic thing
you can do with the web audio api like
creating waves
which uh i think is really awesome but
it doesn't sound so good
what really sounds good is uh
songs so
let's play a song
so
first we have to load a file so now we
create an xml http request which is
really easy because with javascript
developers we know how to do that
let's play get lucky whoa
that's very original and there's a
we need to set the the response type to
arraybuffer because we're dealing with
binary data here and on load we're going
to process the file
very simple uh
processing
yeah processing the file means
we have the context somewhere defined we
need to decode all the audio data that
we have so we put in the response
this is the success callback
which will give us a buffer buffer is
something that we can use to play that
song if something goes wrong there's an
error callback well
i hope
it works today
it worked yesterday so now we need to
play it
playing a sound file is
also fairly simple we have the
context and we create a source node a
buffer source node from it
we assign it the buffer we just got back
from the xml http request then we
connect the source to the destination
and we say start zero
so oh yeah actually let's uh
let's play uh get lucky
you might not have
this song is not available in your
country oh please go to your local
gma office they will tell you why
ah
yeah we're in germany so we we actually
not allowed to play that song yeah so
let's play something that's uh oh
unstable apis i'm sorry
that's that was not planned
oh no no it's gone
so you have to bear with me now
already
perfect
that was a good sound
so uh let's play it i said that i played
deaf punk ha ha and now let's play an
actual song that's hopefully uh
gamer free and the the author is in in
the room
we
okay that was easy um
playing sound uh we could do that with
the old audio tag but now we have more
control about what's happening
what else can we do we can do filters
like what is the filter when it comes to
audio the filter is something
that
manipulates the frequency spectrum for
example
a low pass filter might only allows
lower frequencies and
removes all the others
and most basic filters already
implemented so we can use them
of course you can create your own
filters to do really crazy stuff
uh that's one of the things that's kind
of i will not try out today because it
kind of breaks sometimes
and it's really hard to understand so
let's create a really simple filter like
this is a
bi-chord filter we always create it from
the context we say the type it should be
a low pass
as i said only low frequencies and then
we set the frequency value of this
filter to 100
it's not important what that means but
what's really important is we now
connect the song to the filter and then
the filter to the destination so that we
have a setup like this like
so the filters in between and can
manipulate the audio
uh yeah let's play that
it might not sound so good
and that's really easy to do
so and now i have to say that when you
have the oscillator and the filters you
can actually
create
music from that but
i will not do that today because it's
really complicated i will focus on
timing because timing is key when it
comes to audio when you are banned on
stage
the delay between the instruments is
really important
and
like before
like imagine we were a band and we only
had set timeout and request animation
frame that will really suck because it's
a lot of offset calculations but because
you never know when
the next frame is coming and uh
it's
so inaccurate like even
pro musicians couldn't adopt to that
delay
um
but timing in web audio is uh
really easy because timing is always
relative to the current context so we
have the
context.currenttime which is
you play the first note and then the
context at current time is a time bar in
seconds um
that always goes on it's like never
ending
and so we can
if we time something we can do it in
relation to this
and for example let's let's start a
buffer or song in in two seconds so we
we did that before like we have our
source note and
before we set start zero which means
immediately and now we're saying uh
two seconds from now
and imagine you would do that with set
timeout it might not be two seconds
exactly maybe
199 or something
and the start method even has more
options so we can define when we want to
play it like from what
like
do we have an offset in the buffer do we
want to skip to our favorite part in the
song
and for how long do we want to play it
and let's try this out
so
i don't know
play a song i would click this button
and there will be two seconds a bit more
because the song starts with um
um
like
there's nothing in in the beginning of
the song so it might be 2.5 seconds but
it's accurate
trust me
okay
click
okay you got rico um
the best thing is uh the stop method has
the same options
and the very best thing is i can't stop
the song immediately i have to wait two
seconds oh no it's it's running out
damn i spoke too much i will do it again
you're all of the song right so
afterwards i click and then in two
seconds
it's gone
so now let's skip to our favorite part
that's really easy
okay
timing has one thing that's even more
great than
thinking about the now
we can like
set future values for example if we have
a note gain is something like the volume
like how loud it is and we can set a
value at a certain time so we can say
set a song to point to like the volume
2.2
in five seconds and again imagine that
with a
request animation frame oh my god uh we
can even do
more like linear ramp
to value at time is a really nice method
name by the way uh it sets the gain to
zero in five seconds but it will uh have
an interpolation in between so we'll get
slightly
lower over time
okay so now i only try out the first one
now so we play something and then in uh
in five seconds it will get less volume
demos okay
if you want to get into
the web audio api the first thing you
might want to do is like the hello world
and that's a drum machine of course it's
a drum machine like everybody who's been
working with it did it
so i think i open it
here
so how good can you see it
nice so this
like a drum machine is uh well suited
because
it's a lot of timing involved and you
load buffers and you have the bpm and
you have to adopt to it so i have some
some examples to show like a very simple
beat will be this
yeah
let's add some variation
nice nice okay let's uh do some hip hop
and now
there's a beer challenge like
the person who
guesses correctly the the beat of the
next song
is invited to beer by me like not one
from downstairs because they're free but
at a bar or something
um
okay
let's see because
it starts over
anyone maybe
okay it has something to do with my
twitter name it's uh the death tone
it might be song from the deaf tones
anyone no
oh yeah he knows it around the fur
correct
nice get a beer
thanks
okay um that's like the the the hello
world and there's some other really
exciting demos i will not show this one
because it
like we need a very stable internet
connection i know it's kind of stable
but anyways
but there's jam with chrome which is
like ah it's reloading
oh it worked perfect
yeah it might not work look so well on
that screen though
but
it actually allows you to play
fake
like real fake instruments
with your friends um
and you can just like now i have a
okay i can do that
something like that and
imagine that playing with five of your
friends and like everybody's playing a
different instrument it's like really
fun over the internet of course uh yeah
that's a more sophisticated demo i think
i think
so that's web audio
let's talk about game pads in gaming
like there are more and more complex
games written in js like we have canvas
now with webgl and it allows us to do so
many cool things
but controlling games is really like
it's still old-fashioned we have the
wasd the arrows mouse and keys like ah
there's one problem with that because uh
it's the digital versus analog so wasd
is a digital
way of controlling the game because you
only know if a button is pressed but
know how hard it's not how hard it's
pressed
and like a gamepad like this
has analog sticks which gives you way
more precision and that's uh way more
suited for some of the games
uh wouldn't it be nice
to use gamepads in your browser would be
right
yay we got the gamepad ipr now so we can
use all our favorite gamepads in the
browser
how do we do it
so it's really simple again it's only
webkit i'm sorry firefox
we simply get all the gamepads that are
connected
and then we say ah the first one is it's
an array so it's zero
and now we want to read the buttons the
buttons is just uh something that lies
on the object it's an array of 17 yeah
this has 17 buttons
really
and the but like if
it's also an array so i can say okay
button 0 is uh
currently has the value of zero which
means it's not pressed one it's pressed
uh yeah but that's still digital let's
do some analog things it has x's and the
x's are the analog sticks
same thing as for the buttons but this
time we get float values
which is awesome
and um
yeah we have all the indexes but how am
i supposed like uh which one is
seven on this one
i don't know but ah
fortunately it's uh
standardized uh
let's zoom in a bit
so if i have
the up button on the d-pad it's always
button 12. like no matter what gamepad
you're using like ps2 uh ps3 and xbox
it's always the same and that's really
awesome
so just a quick demo of
how it looks like so these are all the
buttons that i have on this one
and if i now
use this one
like an analog value here you can see we
got float float values and then if i
press the the a button it should be the
one on the pad yes it works nice
so it's really standardized so you can
rely on it
but yeah did you notice something
look closely again and something's weird
about this
um
any guesses
it's it's correct
like there are no
problems okay i'll tell you what it's
not event driven like not at all we have
to read out the state and then
we don't get an event when when
something's uh pressed
so this is why because the the api is
designed for usage in games and uh games
often or most games have an update loop
where they update their state and this
also includes the gamepad states so it's
a
request animation frame again
sadly for this api
because we have to pull the state every
time now uh but events may be added in
the in the future
i think firefox already has some events
for connecting devices
okay let's try something and that's
okay
a live performance now
it's fun for you
not for me
uh it doesn't work so well uh i i was
trying to okay i skipped this i wanted
to show you that i actually press uh the
buttons you have to trust me now have
you have you seen this doodle
it's uh it was doodle for the olympic
games and
you could use it with your um
with the keyboard but also it has
support for um
gamepads and nobody knew that like they
announced it but nobody
used it and so yeah i could do this but
i can also do it like this and then jump
i'm good
nah
come on
last one no
yay
that's pretty nice i want that
more
more games please
game developers
what they know about it so what how do
we combine the web audio api and uh
the
um the gamepad api so it's it's really
simple and i can try with this one and
for the next demos i will perform live
on stage and i never did that before so
uh
it might not be so good so
i'll do a quick demo with this one
okay
oh
yeah nice
okay
uh
well
it doesn't really feel so nice to do
with this uh controller so
uh let's go
back with like
let's talk about gamepads again what
what is a gamepad like
i came up with this if it has a button
it's a gamepad it's duct taping and so
assuming that this only works if your
browser knows
the gamepad
luckily the browser actually knows some
gamepads and
for example you know this one like oh
have you do you know it
guitar hero amazing game it has buttons
like here
so um
i brought one
of course
i
see
oh that's no good
that's good
okay
um i made a little demo it's called
guitar js or in german it's aligned to
halter js
it's like solo entertainer
uh yeah i shouldn't forget to tune the
guitar
okay let's see oops
which one am i using no i don't know
which one is it
okay
should be number one
um what you see here is uh the four
buttons
that i have here like i have five but
this one's not working
exactly um
so can only play really
like really really easy songs with it
and uh
like i used to play guitar when i was
young
uh that but i got old and um
i stopped playing guitar when i went to
uni and i never had a gig in front of
more than like two people so
yeah like my first big audience
um
but actually let me just uh try how hard
three to six everybody knows the song
it's not to be a challenge now uh
because it's far too obvious
okay
damn it
but yeah it's not so fun to play alone
and
sadly there was one thing happening
just yesterday uh
do you know
uh rock band it's a game for the xbox
and like i i used to have the drums like
i had them and no i borrowed them from a
friend
and they broke down so originally my
plan was to
get someone from the audience
to uh play the the drums with me or i i
play the drums because the guitars is so
easy so everybody of you could do it uh
but they broke down
like yesterday i was like oh what
am i going to do
uh so i got a shitty recording of that
song and um
filtered out most of the guitar parts so
i can now
bring my own drum player like pressing
this button
okay let's let's put this away
still connected okay there there are
more controllers actually like that's
that's really amazing uh let me
reconnect this one i hope it doesn't
break now
ah it's not working it didn't break yet
but
okay
oh it's connected perfect do you know
this one
no okay it's not that
well known although uh
it's it's the dj hero turntable and
dj hero is like the same as guitar hero
but with the turntable and so
okay maybe this one like i tried it out
in uni and it's like maybe i can use
gamepad api with it and it's like turns
out you can
so i made a quick demo
oh yeah push the button as if you're
just relaxed right
like
um
i'm fairly new to djing
i kind of started
yesterday
so i'm number two
again this is um
which one should i use this one
uh
this one is so you can see what i'm
doing on that thing that i connected um
yeah i will explain what i'm doing while
i'm doing it
i hope it works so i can press this
button or
if i press this button it should start
playing
and it doesn't that's perfect
okay okay
let me just again let me try this out
oh what
i'm sorry
oh yeah no no it's working perfect
the button wasn't working well that's
okay i can just pray
oh
it's playing already
thanks
i forgot
let's put some environment oh that's
that's too much
okay
thanks
um let me see if it's working yes let's
let's start the song
it's
okay for some reason it's not really
working
just listen to the song while i'm
fixing things
if it doesn't work now you have to trust
me that it works
normally it does
maybe i broke this one too i don't know
okay
perfect what i just did is i pressed the
q button cueing is something that djs
use to repeat parts of the song so you
press the button once it starts kind of
recording the song and then
if you press it the second time
the audio will loop that section
and
it's hard for me because i'm not trained
at this but i try to
mix the song in a nice way no
um
you already know the song so i should
not
don't need to ask
okay
like a dj i'm not doing anything
so
i just
cute part of the song
it's not very like
there's something
it wasn't very precise
but what can i i can do now is
alternate the volume
but i can also
add some more bass
towards my
bass sounds nice
um
i have to wait and split
i don't need to do anything
like
have you seen the gamepad it has like
this this spinning thing uh
originally you you use it to like
scratch
but scratching uh
i can't do it like i could maybe but the
web audio api doesn't allow me to
scratching uh needs something like
being able to play a buffer backwards
so we have a playback rate on on a
buffer and we can say
play it at the normal speed it's
playback rate one
would be really nice to have like
negative values so we played backwards
we don't have it but i can do like
make a nice outro now
like freestyle
and it's good
yeah resetting controllers is nice you
have to remove the batteries
okay let's go on
there are some problems i have with the
web audio api and it's still very
unstable and browsers may really crash
uh when doing really fancy stuff
and as i said there's no negative play
rate so we won't have like scratch.js uh
it's okay
um
would be really nice to have like the
current time of a buffer node like when
i have the current time of the whole
track but not the the current time of
one buffer that i'm playing and i need
to calculate like offsets for that that
would be really nice to have at current
time
uh there's only one destination for now
again a problem for djs like a dj has
two turntables and he listens to the
song on the right but he's playing the
song on the left and then he fades
between this well you can only do that
if you have like two song cards
because you need to listen to that one
but the other one's playing how do you
do that with one song card and
it does like we only have one
destination for now it would be really
cool to have like two so we have djs
like proper djs
uh no
yes
actually yes you could do that
but then
yeah
yes if you have 5.1 yes it doesn't work
for stereo because then you would have
crappy sound okay some problems with uh
gamepad api uh it's unstable so unstable
meaning like firefox and chrome are
highly inco incompatible um
maybe because of chrome having the
prefixes and firefox having some events
in there uh it's really like there are
some polyfills that fix it i want events
please i'm javascript developer i need i
need events for games it's okay but i
need events
and i want to talk to the gamepad like
it doesn't have
like rumble like this one has a rumble
but it doesn't like i can't talk to it
or some
uh game pads have leds and i will be
really awesome to talk to them
yeah it's sometimes unstable as you've
seen like it doesn't connect the game
pads properly
it's too good it only happened once
today and
please at the gita hero 1 drum kit
because i have one at the office and i
could use it so we can have a rock band
js but
we need to wait for browsers to
implement that okay wrapping up
web audio api is like incredibly
powerful i haven't shown you everything
and uh it's really amazing
gamepad api is awesome and it's so easy
to use if it works and
when combined like they they allow us to
play real instruments if we have like
controllers that look like real
instruments and we can fake to play a
real instrument and that's really fun
you can try it out maybe
no not on the party but just ask me and
i'll tell you how to do it and
i can see things like garageband js with
like dj equipment in future only just in
your browser that would be really nice
and uh
i'm yeah montgomery this is my twitter
handle i'm jeremiah on github and
please contact me if you want to found a
javascript band very really nice
thanks
you